Hello everyone, my
name is Noel Batista,
I'm one of the
academic medicine
scholars, and today I
will be giving you your
mini lecture for
OMM Lab Number 13,
Lumbar HVLA and
Posterior Counterstrain.
here are your learning
objectives by the
end of the lab you'll
be able to diagnose
type 1 and type 2 lumbar
somatic dysfunctions
you will also be able
to identify indications
and contraindications
for lumbar hvla
and lumbar counter
strain techniques you
will safely perform
lumbar hvla for type 1
and type 2 dysfunctions
and you will learn
to correctly set up
and appropriately
treat posterior lumbar
counterstrain points.
It's important to
remember landmarks
to help with
our diagnosis.
Landmarks to know for
this lab are that the
12th rib attaches to
T12, the iliac crest
height is at the
interspace between L4
and L5, and the PSIS
is at the level of S2.
Let's briefly review
lumbar diagnosis.
First, screen to
identify posterior
transverse
processes which will
tell you the
rotational freedom.
Then use landmarks
to determine
the level of
the dysfunction.
Induce flexion and
extension to the level
of the segment to
determine if it is
a type 1 or type 2
somatic dysfunction.
Remember, if the
segment becomes
more symmetric
in flexion or
extension, it is a
type 2 dysfunction.
If there is no
improvement of
asymmetry with flexion or
extension is a
type 1 dysfunction.
Confirm your diagnosis
by inducing lateral
translation of the
affected segment
to determine the
side bending freedom.
Here is your
friendly reminder to
perform soft tissue
techniques before
performing any
HVLA technique.
There are no absolute
contraindications for
soft tissue techniques,
but some cautions
and relative
contraindications for local
application include any
fractures, open wounds,
soft tissue or
bony infections,
abscesses, DVT,
coagulopathy,
neoplasm, or directly
performing soft
tissue over a site
of recent operation.
HVLA is a passive
and direct
technique.
Accurate diagnosis,
proper patient selection
and correct technique
are key to successfully
performing hvla
as a general principle
of hvla first you will
identify a restricted
segment second prior
to any hvla treatment
always utilize a form
of soft tissue third
you will localize
precisely to the restrictive
barrier, and then
apply a quick, which
is your high velocity,
and your thrust, which
is low amplitude force,
directed to move
the joint past the
restrictive barrier, and
of course, it wouldn't
be a complete treatment
without reassessing.
Absolute contraindications
to HVLA include
no somatic dysfunction,
no consent,
patient intolerance,
osteoporosis,
osteomyelitis,
fractures,
bone cancers,
any hardware in
the joint, and
severe rheumatoid
arthritis.
Relative
contraindications include
acute whiplash or any
acute lumbar pain,
pregnancy,
post-surgical
complications,
herniated discs,
and anticoagulant
or blood thinner use.
For a type 1 or neutral
somatic dysfunction,
we would be using
a long lever with a
rotational and side
bending emphasis. So for
example, if we're
treating L5, neutral,
side bent left, and
rotated right, the
patient lies in the
right lateral recumbent
position with the
physician standing at
the side of the table
facing the patient.
The physician palpates
between the spinous
processes of L5 and
S1 and flexes the
patient's knees and
hips until L5 is in
a neutral position
relative to S1. The
physician further
positions the patient's
left leg so that it
drops over the side
of the table cephalad
to the right leg.
The patient's foot must
not touch the floor.
While continuing
to palpate L5, the
physician places the
cephalad hand in the
patient's left antecubital
fossa while resting
the forearm gently
on the patient's
anterior, pectoral,
and shoulder region.
The physician places
the caudad forearm
along a line between
the patient's left PSIS
and greater trochanter.
The patient's pelvis
is rotated anteriorly
to the edge of the
restrictive barrier and
the patient's shoulder
and thoracic spine are
rotated posteriorly
to the edge of the
restricted barrier.
The patient inhales
and exhales,
and during
exhalation, further
rotational slack
is taken up.
If the rotational
slack or motion barrier
is not effectively
met, the physician
can grasp the
patient's right arm,
drawing the shoulder
forward until rotational
movement is palpated
between L5 and S1.
With the patient
relaxed and not guarded,
the physician delivers
an impulse thrust with
a caudide forearm
directed at right angles
to the patient's spine
while simultaneously
moving the shoulder
slightly cephalad and
the pelvis and sacrum
caudide to impart side
bending right and
rotational left movement
effectiveness of the
technique is determined
by reassessing the
intersegmental motion
at the level of the
dysfunctional segment
here are the
images of the
technique that
we just described
for a type 2 non-neutral
somatic dysfunction
we will be using
a long lever with
rotational and side
bending emphasis for
example if we are
treating l4 flexed
rotated right and side
bent right, the patient
lies in the right
lateral recumbent
position with the
physician standing at
the side of the table
facing the patient.
The physician
palpates between the
spinous processes of
L4 and L5 and flexes
the patient's knees
and hips until L4 is
in a neutral position
relative to L5.
The physician further
positions the patient's
left leg so that it
drops over the side
of the table, cephalad
to the right leg.
The patient's foot must
not touch the floor.
While continuing
to palpate L4, the
physician places
the cephalad hand in
the antecubital fossa
of the patient's
left arm while
resting the forearm
gently on the
patient's shoulder.
The physician's caudad
hand stabilizes L5.
The patient's
shoulder and pelvis
are axially
rotated in opposite
directions. The
patient inhales and
exhales, and
during exhalation,
further rotational
slack is taken up.
If the rotational
slack or motion barrier
is not effectively
met, the physician
can grasp the patient's
right arm, drawing
the shoulder forward
until rotational
movement is palpated
between L4 and L5.
With the patient
relaxed and not
guarded, the physician
delivers an impulse
with the forearms
simultaneously
moving the shoulder
slightly caudate
and the pelvis and
sacrum cephalide.
Effectiveness of the
technique is determined
by reassessing
intersegmental motion
at the level of the
dysfunctional segment.
Here is the image of the
technique we
just described.
Moving on to our
counter strain
techniques.
Counter strain is a
passive and
indirect technique.
Counter strain points
are also called
tender points and
they are discrete
areas of tissue
texture abnormalities
that exhibit
tenderness and respond
to a positional
release technique.
The named points are
found at consistent
anatomical locations.
indications for
counter strain are
acute or chronic somatic
dysfunctions with an
associated counter
strain point absolute
contraindications to
counter strain include
manifestations of
abnormal neurologic
and or vascular
symptoms brought on by
the treatment position
and exacerbation
of potentially life
-threatening symptoms
by treatment position.
Relative
contraindications include
patients who cannot
voluntarily relax,
severely ill patients,
upper cervical
hyperrotation and
hyperextension in
patients with known
vertebral artery disease
and or upper cervical
ligament instability,
inability to
tolerate classic
treatment position,
inability to
effectively communicate,
severe acute
rheumatological flares,
and any signs of
apprehension while
approaching the
treatment positions.
Here are our posterior
lumbar counter strain
points. We have tender
points PL1 to PL5
on the spinous processes
which are located
on the inferolateral
aspect of the spinous
process at the dysfunctional
segment to treat
these tender points
the patient is prone
you will extend to the
spinal level by lifting
the asis on the side
of the tender point
which also rotates the
pelvis and the lower
segment toward and the
upper segment away,
you will side
bend away by
adducting the
lower extremity.
For tender points, PL1
to PL5 on the transverse
processes, the
tender point would be
located on the
posterolateral aspect of the
dysfunctional
segment. The treatment
position will be the
same as noted previously.
Here are the images
of the counter
strain points we
just discussed.
And that
concludes the mini
lecture for this
lab. Thank you.